- Bladesmiths, this is the
strength test.
To test the strength and
durability of your edge,
I'm going to chop into
these bones six times each.
This test is all about what
the bones do to your blades
and not what your blades
do to these bones.
Brian, you're up first.
Swing hard.
I know no other way.
BRIAN: I'm just worried.
They're pretty big bones.
And anybody that
watches this show
knows that edge damage
or blade breakage gets
you sent home pretty quick.
Well, Brian, your
edge held up perfectly.
Awesome.
Other than a whole lot
of bone dust on here,
I don't see any
issue with the edge.
It still seems very sharp.
Very well done.
Thank you.
Matt, you're up next.
Are you already?
I'm as ready as
I'm going to be.
MAN: All right.
MATT: Bone is nasty.
I'm nervous about the
epoxy I put on the blade.
I'm just hoping this
knife's going to hold.
Well, Matt, the
epoxy stayed on.
Good deal.
[laughter]
There's some chipping that
happened up here at the edge.
But the whole thing
held together.
Well done.
Thank you.
Tyler, you're up.
You ready?
I want to do it.
But I'm ready.
TYLER: I think that my knife's
going to destroy the bone.
Fragments are going
to fly everywhere.
I'd swing at those bones
till either I broke down
or the blade broke down.
I was hoping it would cut
all the way through it.
Well, Tyler, there is some
chipping along the blade
here from the bone.
And the handle is very round.
It just wasn't super duper
comfortable in my head.
But overall, well done.
- Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Up next is the sharpness test.
And for that, I
give you to Dave.
All right, gentlemen, to test
the sharpness of your blade,
I'll be slicing into
those ropes three times.
Brian, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Let's go.
DAVE: OK.
All right, Brian, it's
a very sharp blade.
And they cut the
rope pretty cleanly.
But it wasn't able to cut
very deeply because that edge
geometry is very stout.
As far as the feel goes,
it's a little bit square
on the back of the handle.
Right here, it'd be nice
to see that rounded over.
But it's definitely a cutter.
Thank you.
DAVE: Matt, you ready?
Let's put it on the floor.
DAVE: OK.
- Yes!
- Good job.
[clapping]
This fix you came
up with was ingenious.
I call that epoxy Damascus.
DAVE: [laughs] Your
edge is extremely sharp.
I mean, you can see
it's cleanly cut.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Tyler, you ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
OK.
Tyler, you can see,
your rope, it's cut.
The issue I have is
with this handle.
I had to adjust after every hit.
Every time I hit, that
knife would roll in my hand.
There's just no
contouring to it.
It makes for a very
difficult knife to control.
Bladesmiths, the judges have
completed their deliberation
and they've made
a final decision.
It's time for
another elimination.
Tyler, your blade
did not make the cut.
Tyler, we've always said that
the handle is what connects
the end user to the blade.
Your handle was a little bit
on the cylindrical side, which
makes it hard to hold on to.
And your blade took some damage.
And it just wasn't the sharpest
out of your competitors.
For those reasons, we
have to let you go.
All right, Tyler, please,
surrender your blade.
TYLER: From the damage that
was done from the bone,
it dulled the piss out of it.
But I've learned more in the
past few hours than I have
since I've started
bladesmithing.
And I believe it
will make me a better
bladesmith in the future.
[music playing]